okay okay you could argue I think I I  think you know deep down that men aren't  lined up to date them but if you want to  believe that but let me just tell you  the reason why so because if  historically we wanted a man that could  protect us and take care of us  financially yes so if he did that so  back back in the old days if I found a  guy that slept with you you and you then  I want him because oh he could protect  and take care of her her and her so I  want to get on that train so that's what  but we can't undo our biological route  so we still feel the way we feel about  it so you're saying that it this is the  second in summer summer is what you're  saying you're saying that when from a  perspective of a woman when I see a guy  who's been more promiscuous I will see  him biologically as a better provider  yes